[Music]
please welcome carrie martin lashley yay
i am so excited to meet you um and i was
just wondering like
how
was it when you first came in america
introduced you
saying that she brought you into play
this character
but what was the experience like for you
on your side
um my gosh from the start i honestly
didn't i didn't think i could play ana
morales because i
had been in this industry for a few
years with the idea of
um a stereotype that the industry wanted
to put on a latina actress and when i
walked in and i didn't have to put on a
fake accent or anything like that i
remember marvin being like
i was like i'm sorry i really can't do
an accent so i'm just going to give it
to you like this and he was like you are
enough
and those words have stayed with me for
the last two years it just really
changed my
my mindset my perspective
it is
it is shocking to me um how the system
can work
um i can only imagine how refreshing it
was to be encouraged to be yourself yeah
um and i'm so glad that america provides
those types of environments and shows
that's at the core of it i think what is
so special about this project for us and
the whole season too takes place in you
know pop being released from detention
to like the decision right will he get
to stay or will he be deported and the
whole season is watching this family
live life that yes there's anxiety and
fear and the unknown but there's also
humor and joy and laughter and a
horrible thanksgiving dinner because
because life you know happens and
because we're full complex humans we
don't just sit around all day and be
like who's going to get deported today
you know like that's maybe a part of the
story uh for some of us but it's not the
whole story we're full humans and we're
like funny and sexy and awful too i am
such a romantic at heart and one of the
things that really captivated me about
you beautiful women
uh was your love stories with your
husbands and i was just curious if you
would tell us both about how you met
them and a little bit about it because i
was so swept up in it i've been with my
husband 16 and a half years now and you
met like making a student film together
he was making he graduated from the usc
film school and was making his first
short film and um we met
for
a lunch because he um you know he sent
me the script and everything i was like
oh this is nice but i'm tired i'm
probably not going to do this and on the
last page there was like a press
clipping and i was like ooh who's that i
was like
it hurt to take a meeting
and then and then i forgot about it and
then i showed up and we had a nine
hour lunch
i love this thank you for insulting me
i'm living vicariously through the
beautiful romance that is not fantasy or
television it's really real yeah yeah
okay will you tell me about that so much
um okay so my husband and i met in the
sixth grade
and
we loathed each other so much he picked
on me i picked on him and come eighth
grade i don't know we became really good
friends i think that hatred became
um like and then
in high school we started dating
um against my father's will and
just fast forward
high school college i moved to la
the long distance thing was not for us
so we didn't talk for about
three years in that like distance we
started communicating over like facebook
and then he started coming to visit l.a
and that's one thing led to another and
we were like engaged in like less than a
year i love it
i'm really quickly i know this isn't a
really quickly question but i just have
to ask you also you were pregnant in a
pandemic yeah
how did you handle that it was stressful
i was seven months pregnant when
shutdowns began and it was all we had to
change everything because i was working
in la the plan was to come back to new
york and do everything that i'd already
done with my my son i knew where i was i
i'm like i did this i got this and then
of course it's like the pandemic hit and
we had to switch gears we had to change
doctors change hospitals change
everything but to do it without the like
friends or family or help that you might
normally have it was very intense but
you know she's 18 months old now i like
thriving and just delicious
and she and her brother love each other
and
it's great i mean
i feel like
every day
my goals are just about finding more joy
in my life like we work i mean it's like
what did we take away from this pandemic
if not that nothing is promised to us
right i'm going to make myself cry
you know nothing's promised to us and i
think we all need to
be more gentle with ourselves be kinder
to ourselves if you do anything today
like just
be a little kinder to yourself and and
find a little window to like experience
a little bit more joy every day
that's where i'm at
thank you
thank you
for
that you guys i am so i've been so
looking forward to this conversation and
tentafide which is on netflix in season
two please be sure to watch it and thank
you so much you guys for being here
we'll be right back thank you
[Music]
you